have you ever wondered how much one of
these actually costs Apple to make
unfortunately the company doesn't
release official profit margins for its
devices that's why I reached out to
Counterpoint research for a material
cost breakdown some parts of the new
phone are cheaper but Apple kept the
price we pay the same why is that let's
look at what the researchers found the
best iPhones we've ever created the
iPhone 14 pro Max is the newest priciest
and most feature-rich phone you can get
from Apple it has the biggest display a
more advanced camera and the fastest
iPhone processor so how much does all
that contribute to its cost let's take a
look at this chart as you can see the
most expensive parts were the always-on
display and the processing components
together they make up about 40 percent
of Apple's costs the cellular parts cost
about 13 the cameras including the new
48 megapixel main camera only account
for 11 other small parts like the
buttons speakers and internal
controllers make up the remaining costs
overall Counterpoint says apple pays
about 400 sixty four dollars for the
parts of this phone that's a tad bit
more than what Apple paid for the iPhone
13 Pro Max despite the 17 rise in
material cost Apple kept the retail
price the same generally what it cost to
make an iPhone Trends upward over time
there are two big reasons for this
number one is innovation premium phones
keep getting better and they have to to
get your attention analysts suspect
Apple will continue raising prices to
offset Innovation as you continue to see
more of that Innovation and give the
consumers more of what they want on that
side of things pricing will continue to
go higher the original iPhone reportedly
cost Apple about 218 dollars to make one
of the biggest jumps came a couple years
back between the basic iPhone 11 and the
basic iPhone 12. adding 5G to the iPhone
12 switching from LCD to OLED screens
and other changes raise the cost 26 the
5G components alone tacked on thirty
four dollars but now 5G is the industry
standard and the reverse is starting to
happen the parts that enable cellular
service are cheaper than the previous
generation number two inflation adjusted
for that a 649 dollar iPhone 6 from 2014
would be about 896 dollars today but
over time you do start to get more for
your money a big strategy of apples is
actually to use lower component prices
to pack more great content so
essentially pushing more of the the cost
benefits to the consumer through more
content these percentages are just
calculated estimates because apples
deals with suppliers are top secret
while the iPhone maker releases an
annual list of its suppliers it doesn't
say how much business it does with each
company nor does it describe what the
suppliers do one way apple is dealing
with those Rising costs is by designing
more parts in-house analysts say adding
more homegrown parts to devices should
help bring costs down over time if Apple
wasn't getting a cost benefit internally
designing their own chips they probably
wouldn't be doing it Apple declined to
comment on this report but the company
does control the vast majority of
smartphone industry profits and pushing
premium Pro level devices helps it
retain that lead so I see bigger benefit
for Apple than other Hardware makers out
there like PhD vendors is Apple's brand
allows it to really sustain its elevated
prices this strategy is important to
Apple's biggest smartphone competitor
too Samsung's high-end phones are also
sold for more than twice the cost of
materials the report doesn't tell us how
much Apple spends on other critical
parts of its planning and distribution
we still don't know how much Apple
spends on sales and marketing shipping
or even retail but the report does offer
a decent Glimpse at what you're actually
paying for